here Marie cincacha make their home for  the next two weeks  Katya would later write  um  [Music]  applicable  suddenly the lava plunges down 10 meters  in seconds  foreign  Maurice will eventually emerge from this  crater unscathed and emboldened  don't suppose  in the immense universe that is the  classification of volcanoes the crafts  will eventually adopt two general  classes red  and gray  it was available  red volcanoes like nirogango form as  tectonic plates pull apart and at hot  spots on the ocean floor  magma rises and fills in the gaps opened  up by the movement of the Earth creating  new land  red volcanoes are basaltic  fusive  and up to 1200 degrees Celsius hot